this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace hello and welcome back to
when Fitness turns bad last time we
talked about how pushing yourself too
hard at the gym to achieve impossible
body standards could lead not only to
injury and neglecting aspects of your
life in itself but could even take you
down a dark path towards steroids today
we're going to get even a little more
controversial we'll be looking at the
ways that Fitness can make us elitist
lacking in empathy before exploring the
problematic worlds of red pill Fitness
and the
manosphere so strap yourselves
in Fitness can turn bad when it turns
you into an and unfortunately I
think we're seeing a lot more of that
particularly online as well I'm talking
specifically about people who think that
they're Superior to others because of
their Fitness they think that Fitness
makes them morally Superior that
choosing not to be in Adonis shape makes
you somehow a weak person or a bad
person and I think this is just awful
for starters you have no idea what's
going on in those people's lives there's
a million reasons that they might be
overweight and doesn't even necessarily
mean that they're less healthy than you
maybe they've got better mental health
maybe they are actually pretty strong
maybe they've got good Mobility take a
look at someone like Sam hung there's
plenty of ways to be healthy I call this
a lack of empathy because that's
precisely what it is the reasoning goes
that if I managed to lose weight avoid
becoming overweight in the first place
or build lots of strength then everyone
else should be able to do the same
completely missing the point that
everyone is different and that
everyone's circumstances are different
completely missing that this might be a
personal choice on that person's part
completely ignoring any shortcomings
that we might still have ourselves being
strong and a good weight is a single
metric of health and fitness even can
you touch your toes how's your cardio
why is your definition of Fitness the
yard stick by which everyone should be
measured and no criticism and hurtful
comments do not serve as a good
motivation for those that aren't as fit
as you not according to the science and
not according to common decency and
unfortunately this lack of empathy this
attitude of man up and pull yourself
together actually goes deeper than just
physical fitness one of the most serious
examples of this lack of empathy comes
from the narrative around mental health
I've lost track of the number of times a
fitness influencer has told me that you
can cure your depression by working out
and taking care of yourself the notion
that you can cure depression by working
harder is not only completely lacking an
empathy it's also completely ignorant I
have a degree in Psychology and I don't
consider myself at all qualified to
speak on this subject depression is a
real and serious illness that can have a
vast range of causes from chemical
imbalances to brain injuries to
developmental issues to yes in some
cases acute circumstances but for every
one person helped by this advice there
will be 10 that are harmed seriously by
it and and don't come at me saying that
the situation or the thoughts cause the
chemical imbalances I'm well aware that
this is a complex issue like I said I
studied this it's also a
life-threatening illness and you should
seek professional help if you're
experiencing real depression you won't
be able to Simply get your act together
just like you can't get your act
together if you have pneumonia blaming
people for their depression and offering
asinine Solutions is irresponsible and
moronic but this comes up in my shorts
alongside tips on how to squat properly
ultimately this is often motivated by
the notion that there's some moral
imperative to work out and to be stoic
and strong that it's necessary to
fulfill a masculine role anything else
is weakness convenient isn't it that the
thing you have to do to be a good man is
the stuff you already enjoyed doing not
you know helping to change nappies at
3:00 a.m. people saying that being
strong is important to make them more
masculine or so that they can be useful
members of society again this just
annoys me when was the last time that
you being really strong made you a
useful member of society if you're going
around digging snow off of people's
drives then sure and helping them with
their bins but for the most part there
are plenty of different ways to be a
productive member of society and to be
helpful and to be kind people saying
that they need to be in great shape so
they can protect their family again I
think this is nonsense not only is this
a very rare scenario but there's plenty
of other important ways to protect your
family as well for example learning
emergency first aid would be a better
first Port of Call for most people who
genuinely want to be there for their
being there emotionally and helping them
through hard times is just as important
I just want to make it very Crystal
Clear once again that I'm not saying
that being strong and being able to
protect your family is a bad thing I
think it's a great thing but what I am
saying is that feeling that you can then
look down on other people who didn't
choose to go that route is a bad thing
because there are so many ways to be a
useful and helpful individual that have
nothing to do with masculinity just like
they shouldn't look down on you because
you're not giving half of your money to
charity or not you know part of the
school committee there are so many
different ways to be useful and helpful
being physically stronger or physically
fitter doesn't make you better than
somebody who chooses not to
be basically if you're someone who's
perfect in every aspect of your life
then sure maybe you're in a position to
criticize still kind of makes you an
though otherwise get down off
that high horse if I'm coming across a
bit animated about all this it's because
I've noticed more and more red pill and
hustle culture content Slipping Into
Fitness on social media lately I'm
someone who actively doesn't like this
content and yet the various algorithms
keep dishing it up to me it's as though
Fitness has become a gateway drug to
this stuff you start out searching for
videos on how to get into shape so that
you can feel better and move better the
next thing you know you're learning
which muscles women most respond to the
next thing you're learning how you need
to become a high value man how if things
aren't quite going the way you want them
to it must be because you're not working
hard enough in Life or in the gym in
this way Fitness has become just an
extension of hustle culture which news
flash is not healthy then you learn that
the only reason women aren't responding
to your attempts is that they've been
brainwashed by Society into acting
outside of their natural roles there's
no way that some women just decided they
wanted to you know do other stuff we
hear that society's been feminized and
we're trying to get rid of masculinity
misogyny and a usvs them narrative is
the next step from this and it can lead
to some pretty Dark Places that's why we
get guys like Andrew Tate Who members of
the fitness Community actively defend
because he aligns with some of their
principles I've seen this on so many
podcasts I'm told that if I dislike him
it must be because I'm a sheep or some
such I must be brainwashed because after
all he does occasionally encourage men
to better themselves the slightest
gesture towards doing something
worthwhile never mind that he also says
things like the quote you're seeing on
the screen right
now
it's not okay and it has no place in
Fitness he teaches them that they should
have women that are loyal to them while
they can sleep with as many as they want
some say he's playing an act and while I
doubt that's totally true it doesn't
really matter the fact is he's
influencing young men this way knowingly
whatever the case what do you think
those men feel when their lives don't
live up to the examples he set angry and
entitled that maybe the world is wrong
and the Matrix is out to get them Jordan
Peterson is another one you don't need
to spend long at all on self-improvement
YouTube before he starts getting served
up to you and I think it's pertinent to
bring him up because so many people
defend his points that's because he
seems reasonable on the surface and he
has given some useful advice that's
helped a lot of young men but if we look
a bit deeper and if we read the subtext
there's definitely some red flags here
again if you disagree you must be
brainwashed by the woke media funny how
that works the very people championing
freedom of speech are the most Keen to
discredit those that disagree with them
Peterson seems reasonable and is well
spoken from what I gather he doesn't
much like Tate but he is very much part
of the same problem though he claims to
be neutral and to believe in a balance
of Chaos and Order he clearly has an
agenda to
push and frankly the intellectual dark
web is just a step removed from the
manosphere and the red pill movement
take his stance against Bill c16 that
initially brought him notoriety he
vehemently denied that this had anything
to do with transgender issues and was
entirely about compelled speech except
that the amendment actually had nothing
to do with compelled speech and nothing
to do with pronouns the amendment was
simply about protecting transgender
people from discrimination in the same
way that other minorities already were
Peterson was clearly aware that this was
a mischaracterization and that became
all the more clear when he told Kyle
kinky that the reason he opposed the
bill was because he could see that it
would lead to confusion about gender
identity so kind of flip-flop
there but this is reflective of his
strategies overall he claims he's
innocently sparking debate on difficult
topics but he only ever does this in a
way that encourages hysteria and props
up the status quo as we see his
explanation flip-flop here we see this
in action it was never about freedom of
speech other common strategies include
making sweeping statements or
referencing facts without giving sources
of course Peterson doesn't like it if
you read into his implications because
he's not political he'll tell you that
these are all the uncomfortable
conversations that we need to have but
we can't have a civil discussion except
we've been talking about these things
for decades most of Peterson's ideas
seem to come from KL young and n n being
the one philosopher that everyone has
read to try and look edgy and
philosophical there are other
philosophers guys KL young being Freud's
prote whose ideas have never been taken
seriously by psychologists even back in
their psychodynamic Heyday Peterson is
also well known for using a study on
lobsters to demonstrate the importance
of hierarchies in Social structures but
even this argument is based on a
complete misunderstanding of how
serotonin Works differently in lobsters
and humans and I bring this up again
partly because people put Peterson on
this pedestal because he's a doctor not
actually questioning his sources or his
reasoning and why am I telling you this
have I completely lost the thread now
it's because once again Fitness and
self-improvement content leads people
especially young men down a dark path
see Jordan Peterson claims that he's out
to protect young men he says that
they're being demoralized and
essentially targeted just for being male
he says that we're scarring the youth
with horror stories about climate change
is it any Wonder so many men are
disenfranchised and lost again this
sounds like a noble cause it sounds
great until you ask how exactly are men
being demoralized I'm not saying there
aren't issues facing young men but
nobody has explicitly accused young men
especially young men of anything his
implication is that feminism and wokeism
are attacks on hegemony like so many he
intentionally conflates the term toxic
masculinity to pretend it's a
denouncement of all male traits he
denies the existence of a patriarchy a
gender pay Gap simply saying that other
groups deserve equal rights is in no way
demoralizing or at least it shouldn't be
saying certain power structures favor
certain groups more than others is in no
way an attack on masculinity this is
nothing but a straw man argument and one
that serves to create outrage and
further resentment by using the rhetoric
he does he greatly increasing division
online he claims that's the fault of the
media but terms like postmodern
neo-marxist are intentionally loaded and
unfounded with the explicit purpose of
fueling fear and hate that's a
technically inaccurate term used for no
other reason than to generate hysteria
preventing a proper discourse random
attacks on swimsuit models and
transitioning celebrities on Twitter
again only serve to create controversy
and vitriol and to reveal his true
nature and while it might be nice to
pretend climate change isn't happening
it's the younger Generations that will
suffer if we get this wrong Peterson
makes wild sweeping statements about
climate change just like he does about
so many things which have all been
debunked by people far more educated on
the matter than him what happened to the
difficult conversations we need to
have but I would argue that it's
precisely this narrative and others like
it that's making guys feel like they're
being attacked making them feel marginal
ized creating this usvs them narrative
so I'd argue that on the whole he's
doing far more damage to the mental
health of young men and to the you know
civil discourse among Society then he is
doing
good guess what Buzz Light Year
featuring a gay kiss has absolutely
nothing to do with why you aren't
wealthy or why women don't throw
themselves at incels you aren't striking
out at the bar because feminism exposing
White Privilege isn't an attack on you
or your earning potential you AR feeling
lonely because the world has turned on
white males that's the demographic that
still has by far the most opportunities
that's not to say that you personally
aren't struggling or that there aren't
issues that face young men in fact there
absolutely are in particular everyone is
kind of struggling right now none of
this is to take away from the very real
challenges you might be dealing with
challenges that may well be unfair but
don't blame the wrong people young men
are being taught to blame other
struggling groups minorities that are
likewise just trying to get a bit of
representation and Fitness on social
media is working as a recruitment drive
for these ideologies it's a direct path
to just the right kinds of
disenfranchised guys the tech Bros are
also often only a few steps removed from
this kind of content too I'm not saying
that they're malicious or even wrong
necessarily but often pedaling easy
solutions to all your problems that are
often entirely disconnected from reality
for most people and the other reason
this is all relevant is that we need to
remember that there is an epidemic of
steroid abuse including many underage
individuals people are destroying their
health and risking their lives because
that's what a lot of this content is
telling them they need to do in order to
be accepted in order to make it to the
top the statistics vary but it's
estimated that somewhere in the region
of half a million to a million young men
in the UK are taking this route and it's
terrible that Fitness is what got them
into this now we can just tell young
people not to do steroids we can warn
them of the dangers but we shouldn't
underestimate the promise of becoming an
alpha male they'll keep doing it as they
have been and doesn't help when they
have an echo chamber of other people
telling them that this is the way to get
to the top instead then we should unpack
the ideologies behind this the notion
that we can and should get to the top by
embodying that hegemonic ideal the truth
is that this won't work and has never
worked because it's just transparently
desperate you can't just decide you want
to be more Alpha think about the nerdy
kid that you knew at school imagine he
one day comes in wearing a leather
jacket and smoking do you think he now
gets bullied less or more and do you
think suddenly gets all the girls guys
trying to become high value trying to
become alpha male reek of that same
desperation they are that nerdy kid
wearing a leather jacket thinking
they're the fonds and then they wonder
why girls don't want them and if you
feel like a loser so you start taking
steroids then you're not suddenly going
to become a gigachad you're just going
to be a loser now with tits you know or
dead the truth is of course that you
were never a loser you just needed to
find a way to become the most awesome
version of whoever you are through
genuine self-expression because people
can see the difference and honestly
what's far more important for Success
when it comes to dating gaining the
respect of other men and even
progressing through your career is
emotional intelligence it's
self-awareness it's understanding how
you appear to others and being mindful
of what you say now these aren't things
that are easy to just learn either but
focusing your time on emotional
intelligence and self-awareness will
serve you a lot better than all this
alpha male BS and a lot of this starts
by just learning to relax and laugh at
yourself by easing up and just having a
bit of fun taking yourself too seriously
is such a turnoff the hierarchies are
arbitrary and you are not entitled to
anything nor should you want to be you
don't need to measure your success by
anyone else's yard stick certainly not
Andrew Tate's or Jordan
Peterson's so where does Fitness fit
into all this well seeing as I don't
think Fitness has anything to do with a
moral imperative or being a man and not
to compete with other or to push
yourself harder and harder to become the
best it stops being a grind instead we
can use Fitness to Simply move better
and to feel better and to accomplish the
things that we want to accomplish it
becomes a genuine form of
self-expression and freedom as you learn
to craft the body that you want and to
use it to achieve the things that you
want to achieve we do this by combining
aspects of different Fitness modalities
not getting into that tribal mindset not
ignoring other aspects of our fitness
just because we're so wed to one school
of thought
likewise I think that Fitness itself
best serves us as part of a balanced
lifestyle just like I think that we
should Train by using a combination of
different training Styles I likewise
think that Fitness itself should only be
part of a broader lifestyle yeah it's
great to work on side projects or side
hustles but they likewise shouldn't be
dominating our time and our thoughts not
to the point that we're forgoing social
experiences whilst we're still young
whilst we can still enjoy them we should
be exercising yes working on projects
yes pursuing career yes but also
enjoying ourselves spending time with
loved ones and family and friends
traveling and just relaxing and
unwinding and not always feeling the
pressure to achieve and to
push I'm well aware this is probably
going to upset some people rub some
people up the wrong way I'm well aware
it's probably career suicide I'm not
going to dwell on this stuff a lot in
future videos you can rest assured we'll
be back to the regular programming soon
it's just that with so many videos out
there promoting these ideologies I think
it's important that we occasionally
create videos like this to provide the
alternate perspective to hopefully
balance things out a little bit it's
just something I felt I needed to do
it's something I'm passionate about I
care about Fitness and about the fitness
community and I just wanted to put in my
two cents I hope you guys will forgive
me and you know what if you find
yourself obsessing about this stuff too
much to the point you think it's
unhealthy then consider getting some
therapy or some psychological help
certainly no sh that it's bodybuilding
for the brain it's really good for you
it'll help you to optimize yourself in
more ways than you can imagine and it
could save you from some really dark
stuff anyways guys I'd love to know your
thoughts down below let me know in the
comments what you think how else can
Fitness turn dangerous turn damaging I'm
sure it could lead to some interesting
discussion and I look forward to reading
it either way guys thank you so much for
watching this one and I'll see you next
time bye for
now if you're looking for a new project
consider building a website whether
you're building a website to further
your career career promote your business
or simply to express yourself this is a
fantastic way to put yourself out there
and hone new skills thanks to
Squarespace today's sponsor this is
something that anyone can try
Squarespace makes it extremely simple to
build a website in a matter of minutes
you'll start by selecting the template
you want and then drag and drop elements
to customize it how you see fit there's
no coding required and it's extremely
intuitive while you can have something
modern and professional up and running
in minutes though you can go on to
further customize and grow your site as
you see fit Squarespace comes with all
the tools you could possibly need to do
this builtin that includes Advanced
formatting tools that you create and
share beautiful blog posts or schedule
them for later it includes an in-built
commenting system with threaded comments
replies and likes it includes member
management e-commerce gated members only
content and much more and thanks to the
thousands of available plugins you can
take this even further adding things
like global Shipping and inventory
management for your e-commerce solution
the sky is truly the limit so if you
want to find out more head to
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com bioner for
10% off your first domain or website
thanks again to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video and bye for
now